hi there steve kaufman here
today is the day that i reached 100 000
subscribers
thank you very much
and if you enjoyed these videos please
subscribe
10 years ago 2007 i was 61 years old
today i'm
71 will be 72 in october
i created my first video which i called
the chair and i used my computer
to take a video of my webcam on my
computer to take a video of myself
sitting in this chair and it was more or
less a trial like what happens how do i
upload this and so forth and so then but
it's remained it's the chair you can
find it
and then i started
making videos on the subject of language
learning
the purpose of course was to promote
um
our language learning website which at
that time was called the
linguist um
first of all i should say
that
in the 10 years between between 2007 and
2017
between the ages of 61 and 71 i have
learned eight languages to varying
degrees
and i'm learning them faster and faster
because link is getting better and
better and because i think i'm becoming
a better and better language learner so
you know russian took an awfully long
time and then korean czech
you know romanian portuguese what else
do we have here polish
uh
and i forgot one
but at any rate i'm on greek oh
ukrainian is in there so eight languages
right now i'm working on greek
um
the
site is becoming much faster the
availability now of of these apps to use
on your iphone ipad android
uh
i think some of the content for example
these mini stories that we're developing
now which have been tremendously useful
for me in learning greek i think they're
great
all of this makes it easier and easier
to learn so as i look forward to the
next 10 years i expect to learn like i'm
certainly going to go after arabic the
writing system kind of scares me but
i've got to tackle that writing system
if i do that for arabic then i'll do
farsi
and of course we got turkish at link
and eventually i've gotta also attack
the you know south asian you know
languages perhaps hindi
uh
so that's what i got to look forward to
now how did i ever get there in the
first place so 2007 was the first video
but my life working life has been first
of all seven years as a diplomat and
then from 2000 from
basically
1974 uh
i was in the lumber business initially
working for large corporations and then
i set up my own company
and so that's been like 30 some odd
years that i've been in the uh
you know 40 years oh wow
that i've been in the in the lumber
field so why do i get into language it's
a long story um
i think around the year 2000 i thought
gee it would be good to really get a
hold of cantonese i kind of said a few
things like nehoma or whatever but i
wanted to learn to speak it properly and
so i discovered that there was a thing
called a minidisc player which to me was
amazing many disc player and online
uh dictionaries
but it started with a minidis player so
i've got people
to record stuff in cantonese for which i
had the text witness which i knew how to
read in mandarin
and so i started listening a bunch to
these minidisc
minidiscs that i had and then i started
uh recording the radio and they have
these cantonese talk shows here in
vancouver and so eventually i started uh
listening to cantonese radio
occasionally phoning in and speaking in
cantonese and i discovered that there
was a chinese immigrant
who had come to vancouver and had all
his money stolen all his life savings
stolen at the airport
and since my company at that time was
involved in in creating
software programs for sawmills which we
were selling in scandinavia and the
baltic states
uh we said well we'll give this guy a
chance you know we'll hire him if he's
good that's great for him and great for
us if he isn't very good then at least
we helped him out
and gave him a chance to work you know
in an environment here pick up some
english and stuff and we discovered that
his english was a real problem and so we
devised a program for him
based on how what i will always would
have liked to have had for my learning
you know learning german and spanish and
whatnot and that is to say um some
system for easily uh looking at words
and phrases saving them reviewing them
and if possible tying it to audio and so
that was kind of in a nutshell and so we
developed a system for learning english
which we called the linguist
um
so that's where my involvement with this
whole language thing began
um
to promote the linguist i wrote a book
called the linguist
which was uh written in 2002 two thou
published in 2003
um
in my videos of course i referred to
myself as the linguist which got
everybody all upset that is those people
who uh study linguistics they say you
can't call yourself a linguist and of
course dictionary definition makes it
very clear that for most
english-speaking people
and this is going back hundreds of years
someone who speaks a variety of
languages is known as a linguist
polyglot has become perhaps a more
popular term amongst people who who know
what the term means but i still believe
that a majority of native speakers of
english don't know what the what the
term polyglot means but i'm more
comfortable using the term now in fact
there's a whole community of polyglots i
go to conferences and so on and so on
but i wrote the book then to promote our
site the linguist
and
i also published it in chinese and in
and also in taiwan by the way and went
to china twice gave speeches to
universities uh in china
uh we had about ten thousand uh sold
about ten thousand copies of the book
each in china and in taiwan
tried to interest the immigration
department here in canada
and um
they wouldn't because they're more
interested in how they can acquire more
funding from the government not
necessarily in how they can help
immigrants learn english
so in the end we decided that we would
change it from an english only system to
a multi-language platform
and look for you know learners all over
the world and that's where link
developed and i can't tell you i can't
remember the date when the linguist
became linked the whole thing has been a
very lengthy process
lots of trial and error
uh you know it's been a long road but
what we have today is just so much
better than what we had way back then
it's it's it's not funny
um
so
there you have it um
10 years
look forward to learning more languages
for another 10 or 20 years however many
years i have
we are continuing to improve link
i hope that all of you
continue to pursue your interest in
languages whether it be one language
that you're trying to learn
or more than one language
i can assure you that the first one is
the most difficult because you have to
you have to persuade yourself that you
are capable
of transforming yourself into a person
who can speak another language
comfortably fluently
and i
i'll i'll digress a bit because i gave i
i did a video in french and i said uh
a monavie instead of i said
instead of
of course in french we say
so there was great discussion about how
can you possibly make such a mistake if
you claim to be
level c2 in french
i just want to emphasize that no matter
how good you are in a language you're
always going to make mistakes
and i know people who
i would say master english who have a
vocabulary
far better than the average native
speaker but they occasionally will make
a mistake it may be a habit that is
very deeply ingrained that they
consistently make as a mistake or it may
be a mistake that occasionally slips in
to their language we should not be
afraid of making mistakes
mistakes are how we learn
if we aren't making mistakes we aren't
challenging ourselves enough
so just a digression there
um
10 years 100 000 subscribers thank you
very much
um
[Music]
if you have any comments suggestions
please feel free i think i might often
might also put a uh a blog post up
uh on this subject
uh and there you have it i look forward
to the next 10 years
thank you for listening bye
[Music]
you